hello everyone and welcome to the Havana
Tournament of 1965 which is basically
the capablanca Memorial tournament we've
already covered a few games
um mostly I'm going to be covering the
games that do not end in a draw so first
uh Fisher started with two wins then he
got two draws then that Victor against
the Ring of Darwin C we've seen a few a
few videos back then he got two draws
and now he's facing a very very strong
Grandmaster last lozabo uh who uh is one
of the first Grand Masters he actually
got his Grandmaster title in 1950 as
soon as fide introduced the top before
we only had Masters there was no Grand
Master title but he is one of the first
to receive it and he's been playing
chess pretty much forever uh he was uh
he he worked as a banker even before
World War II and he started winning some
great games even on the international
scene but then during the outbreak of
the World War II uh he was captured and
he was held and only continued his chess
career upon uh uh upon the End of the
World War II now uh this was played in
1965 and already he was quite a beast
then his uh very best performance ever
is considered this tournament here which
is the 1956 candidates tournament that
was played in Amsterdam as you can see
uh Zabo finished in third place or
basically in those days you didn't have
third place you had like shared a shared
a third so he he got shared third with
Boris basket tigrant Petrosian David
bromster and Evan Geller I mean those
are incredibly incredible names and you
can see that the entire uh tournament is
filled only with Incredible names
mirosla philippos carpano Hermann filmi
uh Paul quieres of course the Eternal
second got second place and the
tournament Was Won by none other than
vasilis mislav uh but yeah as you can
see he is a very very strong player and
here he faces another very strong player
which is of course Bobby Fischer so
let's check it out uh they play a line
that played pretty much even today and
you guys will recognize it but then uh
Zabo will make not a mistake or anything
he will just make two slight not even
inaccuracies he will just not make the
absolute top engine move and Fisher will
punish that uh well like you haven't
seen so let's check it out we have Pawn
to E4 uh Pawn to E5 Knight to three
Knight to C6 and of course Bishop to B5
Fisher always went for the Roy Lopez
Ponte A6 morphe's defense with Bishop to
A4 and now Knight to F6 with castles and
Bishop to E7 so all been played before
nothing new here Rook D1 B5 Bishop to B3
and castles we have Pawn to C3 Pawn to
D6 and uh this is still the top played
line even today so here we have a pawn
to H3 stopping the development of the
bishop to G4 and now Bishop to E6 this
is a quite a rare move uh in those days
okay it was played nowadays you will see
a lot more of knights the A5 this is the
standard approach you attack the bishop
the bishop moves then you play C5 then y
plays D4 and so on so this is basically
the main line where you have to decide
whether you want to go Queen to C7 or
Knight to D7 a very very nice line also
you could consider instead of that uh
just going for Knight to ba this is the
brayer variation and also you will shift
your knight to D7 you will play C5 and
so on you could also Play Bishop to B7
so these are all top moves that are
being played today but uh here uh Zabo
played Bishop to E6 and it's not that
it's uncommon today uh for example
mamidara played it against Adams played
it against
Hare Krishna played against narubitsuki
not once did Black actually win the game
in modern times but in those days they
did play it so okay Pawn to D4 Fischer
continues uh with a very principled move
grabs the full Center threatens D5 to
win material so Bishop captures some b3a
captures and now e captures on D4 we
have C captures and now again it's a
known position even today D5 is
considered strongest Knight the B4 we
have here uh Fisher claims the D5 Square
for himself and not Knight the D7 as the
E5 and C5 squares have been vacated as
soon as Fisher pushed D5 Knights to A3
trying to challenge the Knight on B4
with knights the C2 and here again there
is one game where C5 was played but here
we have Bishop to F6 and it is now as of
move 14 that we have a completely new
game so let's see uh how uh how official
continues this we have Knights the C2
challenging the Knight on B4 and just
Pawn to C5 this allows Fisher to double
as double spawns but does he really want
to do it yes he does he plays Knight
captures on B4 C captures and now
Knights the D4 an excellent Central
Square for the Knight where you are
controlling uh a whole lot of squares in
your opponent's half of the board so uh
Zabo decides to give up the bishop for
Knight here and it is in fact the the
proper thing to do this Knight here is
just a monster and if it comes to F5 uh
well it's just not going to be pretty so
uh Bishop captures Queen captures you
will see in a lot of Bobby Fisher the
games even when he's playing against the
absolute top competition that somehow he
always manages to centralize his Queen
and there is there is no peace more
powerful than a centralized Queen so uh
Queen to D4 we have Pawn to A5 and now
comes Bishop to F4 just nicely
continuing development which tempo as
the D6 Pawn is undefended from knights
the C5 and now rookie 3 defending and
attacking you want to play Rook to G6
you want to play uh put pressure on the
black king So Pawn to F6 this makes
sense although it's uh you know
sometimes you don't want to play it here
it definitely makes sense the queen is
no longer as powerful on D4 and you
don't have to worry about something like
rooked G3 Bishop to H6 and so on uh so
Rook 8 to E1 by Fisher and now he has
plans of moving the bishop he wants to
or maybe even bring the Rook here to
help out with the defense of the pawns
but also as F6 has been played uh
official no longer can really execute E5
and so he will move the bishop maybe F
or maybe E5 somehow he really wants to
get it in we have Queen to C7 Bishop to
G3 and now Knight back to D7 we have
King to H2 and now Rook after d8 uh we
have Rook 3 to E2 uh and the Knight to
C5 uh Fisher repeats Rook D3 and Laszlo
repeats nice to D7 and fish are not
really interested in a trade he has to
uh in a draw he has to figure out how to
continue the game so here Queen to D3 uh
re-maneuvering the queen with Tempo is
now the B5 Pawn is hanging now the queen
might be going to the king side uh Rook
8 to B8 defending the B5 pawn and now
Queen to E2 we have Rook to B7 and now
King back to H1 and the position might
open up so you don't want your king
vulnerable here and it's not like black
can stop anything if Fisher wants to
play f for E5 then he will do that so
Knights the C5 and not Fisher Waits no
longer he pushes Pawn to F4
and the the problem is uh you don't
really have a way of stopping E5 even
though you have sufficient control over
the square you just don't have enough
control even with a move like Rook to E8
E5 is still incredibly strong you can
just trade everything let's say captures
captures and the black's position is
completely busted now white will win
this very easily as he has a lot of
attacking potential here and also he
does have the past D Pawn also the queen
is hanging so it's not going to be easy
to to offend off the white forces so
after Pawn to F4 we have rooked the f8
yeah Lazlo has a different idea if E5 is
played then okay he will claim the f
file sorry about that the f file for
himself uh we have found the E5 by Bobby
and now Pawn to F5 not capturing here
very interesting approach and now how do
you continue this this is a very very
tricky position where you could easily
squander your advantage and many would
just push E6 here but the problem with
E6 is that after Queen to E7 there's no
good follow-up it be great if you could
play Bishop to H4 you just can so that's
why Fisher before pushing E6 he played
Bishop to H4 he stopped Queen to E7 and
now E6 E7 will be incredibly strong so
here how do you continue uh well you
could just wait let's see if you play
something like Rook B to B8 then comes
Rook to C1 okay this could be a problem
the queen moves then you push E6 then
white just continues pushing and maybe
black can survive this but chances are
that he can't in the game d captures an
E5 was played which may be giving up the
the central tension a bit too soon but
okay you can't argue with uh with a
player as strong as Zazzle Zabo so F
captures on E5 and now Pawn to F4 this
is how he grabs the f file for himself
but now even though there's only one
move that's winning here for Fisher it's
not that easy to spot as his Rook is
hanging and there's only one square
where the Rook will not be lost and that
of course is the F3 Square so Rook to F3
and now Queen to D7 and now how do you
continue this Bobby play Queen to D2
just nicely calmly defending the D5 Pawn
preparing to capture on F4 if you really
wanted to you could just give up the D5
Pawn like the queen capture spawn to E7
and after Rook d8 you capture an F4 then
this is also possible but no uh pointing
risking too much after Queen to D7
Fischer just played Queen to D2 We have
Queen to F5 and now Pawn to E6 uh we
have Knight to E4 attacking the queen
Fisher just played Queen to D4 once
again a centralizing his Queen and he
was in this position and move 36 that
Lazlo Sabo resigned to the game as
really there is nothing more to be done
here so how is how is it possible that
Fisher played such an incredible game
against such a strong opponent well he
was just that good he's only up a pawn
but you can see that he has a pass to D
Pawn he has a past e-pawn and even if
you wanted to continue this game somehow
let's say go Knight to D6 okay block the
pawn somehow E7 is coming the bishop
here is incredibly strong let's say Rook
d8 because you can't really keep your
Rook on the on the f file uh so Rook d8
now comes Rook captures an F4 you win
another pawn and after Queen to D7 you
can just play Rook to E6 and uh very
very soon you will just resign this for
example Pawn to H6 you will play Queen
to E5 uh double up on the Knight here
and now you lose a piece if you if you
defend and Rook to G4 and now you cannot
defend Checkmate so I mean this would be
this would be over uh very quickly maybe
even quicker than this if the game had
continued but of course uh Laszlo
decided not not to put himself through
any of this uh so yeah very nicely done
by by Fisher I'm really enjoying the
games from this tournament I'm pretty
sure I haven't seen any of the games in
this tournament I have no idea how I've
just missed this in tournament for my
entire life The Havana 1965 tournament
basically the Copa Blanca Memorial so
hope you guys are enjoying them and if
you if you haven't seen that Master
Class Bobby Fisher played against the
Vaseline Smith love in round one of this
tournament uh do check it out it will be
the first link in the description below
it's just a mind-blowing game now so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank James
Eugene Cashman Brad Roth uh
bulletjustthriller.com John Malpass and
Phil Malthus for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day